[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
could convicted sex trafficker elaine
maxwell receive a new trial why a juror
in the case now faces questioning under
oath from a federal judge plus jury
selection will soon begin in the federal
trial of accused sarah lawrence cult
leader lawrence ray and did this ohio
doctor help his patients into their next
chapter or murder them in cold blood
this is the mess they created and not
only with one witness but with two
witnesses and we've been dancing
and tiptoeing around the tulips the
whole time with these report issues but
first the january 6th attacks donald
trump always has a very aggressive legal
team what former attorney general bill
barr says of trump and the insurrection
of the capital law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin former attorney general bill barr
speaks out about his tenure under then
president donald trump this as the
january 6 committee seeks more documents
claiming the former president and others
were engaged in a criminal conspiracy
law and crime's angel levy is here with
what barr had to say as well as thoughts
from a former federal prosecutor
brian bilbar spoke to nbc news and said
if he were a.g he wouldn't prosecute
president trump for january 6 or for
taking classified documents with him to
mar-a-lago from the white house this
comes as new reporting suggests that
trump likely will not face tax fraud
charges in new york
i told him that
all this stuff was bullshit
and
about election fraud former attorney
general bill barr said that conversation
with then-president trump led to him
offering his resignation and it being
accepted just last week the january 6
committee filed documents alleging a
likely criminal conspiracy in the
attempt to overthrow the election the
committee is asking for access to emails
from john eastman a lawyer who worked to
overturn the election eastman has
claimed attorney-client privilege the
committee cannot file criminal charges
only the justice department can do that
so what's the likelihood donald trump
will actually be prosecuted i think
there's only maybe a 15 percent
chance he will be prosecuted by state or
federal authorities jean rossi is a
former federal prosecutor and law and
crime legal analyst he would expect
trump to mount a vigorous defense and i
think the prosecutors
are a little bit
cautious
and afraid of losing the case against
donald trump over the weekend the new
york times reported that manhattan d.a
alvin bragg has concerns over the
strength of the financial crimes case
the office has been presenting to the
grand jury against trump two career
prosecutors have resigned
now the new york times reports that
other prosecutors resigned last year
because they were on the flip side of
that they believed that the
investigation was moving too swiftly and
with this evidence that was being
presented to the grand jury as for that
bill barr interview the former president
sent a letter to lester holt
basically trashing bill barr saying that
his book is fake and generally calling
him slow and lethargic brian
thanks angelette joining us today is
civil rights attorney christa ramey and
terry austin as we discuss the latest in
the events surrounding january 6. krista
wrong but not illegal that seems to be
the takeaway from barr's interview but
does this interview push the needle for
trump legally in any way
i'm not sure that it does and i'm not
surprised that bill barr said what he
said he's a strong believer in the
authoritarian president and whatever
they call it broad presidential powers
and so it's going to mean a lot for him
to believe that trump broke the law
i
i tend to fall on the side of i don't
think that there will be criminal
charges brought
during biden's first term only if biden
is reelected it doesn't make sense and
it's too much of a political question
and i think that that this white house
probably doesn't have the the
political will or strength to you know
push that through yeah now terry former
president trump had some harsh words for
a bar how's this back and forth playing
out for mr trump
actually i think it's playing out very
well for mr trump look his legal defense
seems to be to delay to distract to
disparage others and it's worked for him
so far through the impeachment processes
and now through this litigation the
issue here really is whether trump
inspired an insurrection he either did
or he didn't and the legal defense is
going to be based on the evidence or the
lack of evidence and basically if trump
is trying to say that he had nothing to
do with it so far the delay is really
helping him and var basically disagreed
that the election was stolen but he
basically is defending trump on almost
every single thing else so i think at
the end of the day trump is going to be
successful i agree with gene and i agree
with krista i don't think it's going to
be prosecuted you know i mean let's ask
that question anjanette what is the
manhattan da's office saying about the
story in the new york times
well they're not saying much you know
they've led people to believe that this
is still an ongoing investigation and it
has been going on
for years now but i reached out to alvin
alvin bragg's press office earlier and
they still have not returned my email
that is how they said they wanted to be
contacted about this matter and any
other matters by the press and still no
response
right more investigation more delays of
course will keep eyes on any
developments and bring them back to here
along crime daily switching gears now
disgraced comedian bill cosby will
remain a free man as the supreme court
of the united states rejects a
pennsylvania state bid to reinstate his
sexual assault conviction now back in
2018 qazi was convicted of aggravated
assault for drugging and sexually
assaulting andrea constant in 2004. in
june of last year cosby was released
from prison when the pennsylvania
supreme court ruled in favor of cosby
saying his due process rights had been
violated that ruling stems from a 2005
agreement between cosby and a montgomery
county district attorney where cosby
gave his deposition in exchange for a
decision not to prosecute him in a
statement qazi spokesperson said in part
quote this is truly a victory for mr
cosby but it shows that cheating will
never get you far in life and the
corruption that lies within montgomery
county district attorney's office has
been brought to center stage of the
world
former empire tv actor jesse smallett is
set to be sentenced on thursday months
after being convicted of staging a hate
crime in 2019. in december smollett was
found guilty of five of six felony
disorderly condo charges for falsely
reporting he was a victim of a hate
crime he originally told police he was
attacked by two unknown men who poured
bleach on him wrapped a noose around his
neck and called him racist and
homophobic slurs at trial last year two
brothers testified that smollette paid
them to attack him in an attempt to get
media attention last month smollette
requested either a new trial or that a
judge reversed the verdict he is
claiming his constitutional rights were
violated when his legal team wasn't
allowed to participate in jury selection
meanwhile the chicago police department
is now seeking up to 130 thousand
dollars worth of restitution for
investigating the hoax hate crime
still ahead on law and crime daily
federal trial will soon be in session
for the accused sarah lawrence cult
leader but first comfort care or murder
we head to ohio where a former icu
doctor stands trial for allegedly
killing 14 patients
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily an
ohio trial continues into his third week
of testimony as a former doctor accused
of killing 14 patients faces murder
charges testimony resumed monday morning
after arguments over privileged
information william hussell allegedly
killed over a dozen patients by ordering
excessive and lethal doses of fentanyl
while they were being treated in the icu
the defense team for the former mont
caramel physician claims he was giving
his patients end-of-life comfort care
monday started off with the prosecution
and defense discussing testimony from
two witnesses with a judge continuing
arguments from thursday that they had
relied on privileged information from
confidential reports on thursday husel's
defense moved for a mistrial saying the
testimony prejudiced who sell and that
the reports weren't made available to
the defense prosecutors countered
arguing the expert testimony gave
information based on their expertise
without waving privilege
he testified about some phantom report
of which in fact is his work
his review
of certain privileged documents i would
like to have what he relied on and
that's the only way i can properly cross
examine him if you if you looked at
these papers
i need to see them too to be able to see
if you're lying or not and i can't
so
they can't have it both ways having
their cake and eat it too
and and in fact
the prosecution was aware that this was
based on
on on privileged information and
improperly solicited over our objections
so
[Music]
this is the mess they created and not
only with one witness but with two
witnesses and we've been dancing
and tiptoeing around the tulips the
whole time with these report issues
the judge ultimately decided not to
address the privileged information issue
with the jury questioning moved on to a
new witness monday dr david ralston an
icu physician who worked alongside whoso
during cross-examination he was asked if
there were any complaints made against
husel
you would agree with me that before you
got that call from dr
that at no period of time in 2013
had you ever heard from a nurse any
complaints with respect to doctor
williamson that is correct and the same
question about that year
no complaints in 2013 from any
physicians about dr williams wood
that is correct already
anyone in critical care correct that's
correct
whosoever accused of giving high doses
of fentanyl to his icu patients and was
initially charged with 25 murders 11
were dismissed in january his defense
team argues mount caramel hospital had
known threshold put in place for the
amount of fentanyl that could be given
to patients that has since changed
back to help break down the case of the
accused deadly doctor is civil rights
attorney krista ramey and terry austin
terry there have been multiple experts
and physicians testifying in this case
why do the parties are spending so much
time discussing their credentials
you know what brian that's a good
question it's got to be tedious for that
jury to have to listen to all of these
lengthy qualifications what school did
you attend what articles did you write
what associations are you part of but
it's very important to list all of that
so the jury can understand this is a
qualified person this is someone who is
credible and not only that the judge
actually has to determine whether or not
that witness qualifies as an expert and
can give their opinion that argument you
heard about going back and forth over
what they listened to was it privileged
that's important too because what they
actually read to prepare for that expert
testimony is very important so it's
boring and tedious but very necessary
all right so that's it from like a very
high level in terms of expertise let's
talk about one of those doctors krista
testimony continue with dr ralston how's
his testimony fitting into the trial
well i think it's fitting in um well
actually he's testifying as an icu
doctor
um which is what a rehearsal was and
he's testifying about his custom in
practice and how it differed from the
defendants
and he is while a precipitate witness is
being allowed to give a lot of opinion
testimony um
in front of this jury which
you know some might argue is not
appropriate because he wasn't retained
as a
expert witness and obviously did not
turn over the information that he relied
upon like expert witnesses ordinarily
are required to do all right seems like
ohio's going to another doctor for a
second opinion we'll see if ralston's
testimony is what's needed to uh convict
who cell but of course as the case
continues we'll give you updates here at
law and crime daily and make sure to
watch gavel to gamble coverage at the
law and crime network coming up on law
and crime daily could convicted sex
trafficker elaine maxwell be granted a
new trial
plus an accused cult leader is set to
stand trial for federal sex crimes
extortion and psychological abuse we
break down the case of the sarah
lawrence cult next
[Music]
welcome back the man accused of
facilitating a cult at sarah lawrence
college is set to stand trial in a new
york federal court beginning this week
lawrence ray also known as lawrence
greco faces 17 charges including sex
trafficking extortion racketeering
conspiracy and violent crime in aid of
racketeering stemming from a 10-year
stint as an alleged sex cult leader
prosecutors say ray moved into his
daughter's college home back in 2010 to
get back on his feet after being
released from prison he lived there with
her and her college classmates they say
rey went on to target his daughter's
friends forcing them to partake in
bizarre group therapy sessions forced
labor and sex trafficking prosecutors
also say rey extorted thousands of
dollars from the girls physically abused
some of them and sexually groomed others
facing similar and related charges is
isabel pollock who was once thought to
be a victim prosecutors say ray
recruited pollock into the scheme to
gain trust from other students and
alienate them from their parents jury
selection and raise trial is set for
tuesday with opening statements
expected to be presented on wednesday
long crimes adam classville will be at
the courthouse for capital gavel
coverage
civil rights attorney krista ramy and
co-host terry austin are back as we
preview the sarah lawrence cult federal
trial terry with jury selection
beginning tuesday what defense do you
think ray uh will argue
you know this is a very difficult case
to defend first of all who moves into
the dorm of their daughter i'm surprised
that the college allowed that to happen
it definitely reminds me of the jeffrey
epstein and galen maxwell case that we
recently saw being convicted there sex
trafficking is a horrible serious
offense and if in fact rey's daughter
was a victim that makes it even more
heinous as far as his defense is
concerned i think he's going to have a
very uphill battle it sounds like the
prosecution has a lot of information
they have cell phone videos they say
that they have witnesses some 17
witnesses financial records so i think
it's going to be difficult to defend and
the facts of the case are horrific i
mean krista terry named some of them
already but keith reniere r kelly
jeffrey epstein elaine maxwell new york
federal courts have been going after sex
trafficking in a major way do you expect
lawrence ray to be the next name in that
long list
i do i've noticed that since the me too
movement and i i draw
direct connection with it and
prosecutors are more
vigorously prosecuting these cases and
the defenses of she asked for it or she
consented don't work anymore
and you are seeing these convictions
come down at a greater rate across the
country all right we'll keep an eye on
that again adam classifield is in that
court we'll make sure to get gab with a
gamble code from him and make sure to
check out his tweets they're always
really good
and actor alec baldwin says the russ
movie lawsuits are targeting wealthy
people instead of those who were
negligent in the deadly movie set
shooting over the weekend baldwin was
questioned about the lawsuits at a film
festival in boulder colorado balton
claims that some lawsuits around the
movie are going after the wrong people
saying those who are negligent are the
people with no money while people with
money are the ones being blamed for the
tragic shooting he alleges the lawsuits
are motivated by money this comes after
the family of helena hutchins files a
wrongful death lawsuit hutchins was shot
and killed last october when a prop gun
went off on the set of the western movie
rust baldwin who was holding the gun at
the time claims to have never pulled the
trigger
when we come back the trial of gillane
maxwell did a federal juror lie on his
questionnaire we look ahead to the
juror's testimony under oath will he
plead the fifth or will he be offered
immunity
welcome back to law and crime daily a
juror will soon face questioning under
oath after accusations that he lied on
the juror questionnaire in the elaine
maxwell federal sex crimes trial all
this stems from a juror known as scottie
david who helped convict maxwell of
federal sex trafficking charges in
december of last year on the jury
questionnaire filled out ahead of the
trial david indicated he had not been
sexually assaulted but during
deliberations and post-trial interviews
david revealed he had been sexually
assaulted as a child while judge allison
nathan denied maxwell's defense motion
for a new trial she ordered david to
appear for sworn testimony that's
scheduled for tuesday david has
indicated he would plead the fifth
unless he's offered immunity to testify
according to court records prosecutors
may offer david immunity right now
maxwell faces up to 65 years in prison
prosecutors say maxwell worked with late
financier jeffrey epstein to groom and
traffic underage girls epstein died by
suicide in 2019 before his case went to
trial
all right krista plead the fifth or
testify under immunity what do you think
the prosecution wants here since they
typically give immunity
well you know it's a tough call because
it's their case right and they're the
ones that get to decide whether or not
to give immunity i think in the interest
of justice they're gonna want to give
immunity to this um this juror um you
know
the jurors sometimes want to get on jury
panels you need to get behind the reason
and the motivation for it to find out if
it did play a role
in his you know pushing a jury one way
or the other during deliberations i
think it's important enough that you'll
see immunity given
all right terry let's uh let's speculate
let's imagine let's see how this plays
out but let's say
scotty david testifies that he did lie
on his questionnaire what's the
likelihood maxwell receives a new trial
listen if he does testify that he lied i
think there's a very good possibility
there will be a new trial whether you
want a new trial or not first of all he
either lied or he misled the eternities
now if he gets immunity of course he
won't be held in contempt but any other
juror would be held in contempt if there
is no immunity granted but if in fact he
did lie and it affected the
deliberations that's the whole thing
brian whether or not it affected the
deliberations if it didn't then it could
not maybe be a new trial but if it did
that's important and we have heard that
the fact he was talking about what
happened to him when he was a child and
how the witnesses really could have
forgotten it or how they might not have
reported it for a long time so i do
think that could have affected the
deliberations because he basically
influenced those jurors and the judge
might say at the end of the day that a
new trial is granted here yeah we often
only see that first prong that hey i
lied on a questionnaire or whatever it
may be but i think as your to your point
terry that second part of how it may or
may not have influenced the jury that's
the part at least as me as a defense
attorney i would hang my hat on and i
think uh
i don't really want to see it for the
for the alleged victims in this case to
have to redo a case but here at long
crime daily we would love to see another
elaine maxwell trial that'd be
interesting uh to see how that case
either stays the same or changes anyways
uh krista thank you for joining us terry
always a pleasure and of course thank
you for joining us here at law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you